well tomorrow Labour Party members will
begin to receive their ballot papers for
the party's leadership contest so it's a
crucial weekend for the three candidates
to get their message out joining us now
from Durham we're another round of
hustings will be held later on is one of
those candidates Lisa Nandi thank you
very much for being on the program
this morning so people will be starting
voting next week Keith Starr is the
clear favorite to win the contest how
are you going to turn it around well
exactly the way that we've been doing
this since election day and that
shuttering defeat on the 12th of
December which is going out to members
and making an argument about the fact
that we've been losing now for 15 years
we keep changing the man at the top and
hoping that that will change things but
this was no ordinary election for labour
we lost seats that where people had
voted labour and their families for a
hundred years
they didn't just turn away from us they
turn to the Tories and they tend to the
Tories in very large numbers so when I
launched my election campaign by saying
that labour must change or will die and
the members have been enormous ly
receptive to the idea that we could
become a very different party rooted in
our communities earning back people's
trust showing the difference that Labour
makes on the ground and much more
connected to the top of the party
driving those decisions so that no
longer are we a party that sets our
policy and our direction of travel from
central London hundreds of miles away
from people's lives talking about issues
that sometimes resonate but quite often
are far too disconnected from the issues
that are affecting people whether it's
bus networks or the floods that are
really destroying people's lives across
the country at the moment and the
members have really really responded to
that I think there is a real appetite in
the labour party to win to hold on to
our values and to champion our values
but to go out into the country and win
the argument about those values and that
is what the Labour Party I lead will do
I mean you talk a lot about a disconnect
about the need to be rooted in
communities outside of London and you
mentioned buses and flood defences there
but I mean what is the big idea to do
that what does that actually mean
well I think there's a genuine sense
across this country that people want a
fairer more equal
society when I went to Asheville just
after the election campaign to find out
why people ex- had voted labor nurses
had voted Tory for the first time in
their lives what people told me was a
story about feeling that all the whole
political system is far too remote from
them that's a large extent to why we
voted to leave the European Union in
seats like mine because people just feel
that the political system is just too
unaccountable they want to see
investment and good jobs back into areas
that have been losing them for 40 years
they want to see that spending power
back on the high street they want to see
those institutions valued and in the
cities people want to see a settlement
where people can choose when they move
to the cities for opportunity they don't
want to see a situation where we're
piling people into our major cities
house prices are going up young people
are going into debt air pollution
congestion strain on public services and
enormous inequality is becoming the norm
and I can actually do better for Britain
but there's a lot there over a long time
there's a lot about the problems but I'm
just trying to work out what the
solution is you talk about devious you
need to what about moving Parma out of
London
what's the solution yeah I mean the
answer is power because although Boris
Johnson and the Tories have understood
that there is a need for spending in
other parts of the country spending on
transport on digital infrastructure on
skills so that we can get those good
jobs back into those communities that
have been losing them for a very long
time what they still don't understand is
that the people who are closest to those
communities are best placed to
understand what that is in Grimsby for
example where they're developing an
amazing new wind industry with the help
of the states not the British state the
Danish state that is investing hugely in
that area they are creating
apprenticeships and they've got a real
sense of purpose now and the clean
energy jobs of the future
that's what Grimsby is redefining itself
as I want to see that model rolled out
across the country but the people of
Grimsby know better and their local
leaders than any group of officials of
bureaucrats sitting behind a desk in
central London and the Tories really
haven't understood this yet this is an
opportunity for labour we've got to
seize it okay now you
you've written for labor lists calling
for more support of the media you've
said it's time for all of us to be more
forceful in supporting a free and open
media what do you mean by that well I
think we've seen the same process in the
media that we've seen in politics in
recent decades we've seen the
concentration of opportunity voice
influence in far too small a number of
hands we've seen the demise of local
newspapers which are still a very very
trusted source of news and matter
greatly to people into places but are
really really struggling with the
funding model that they've currently got
we've seen we've seen a small number of
political programs that have a
conversation amongst themselves between
london-based politicians and
london-based journalists in recent years
I have to say this show is different
you've always been very very good at
getting out around the country and the
fact that you're leading on the flooding
at the moment shows that shows like this
are really important because far too
often the country is over here having a
conversation and politics is over
they're having a very very different one
we've got to get a media that is far
more open far more pluralistic and
invests so that we've got investigative
journalists coming through who are able
to properly hold politicians to account
and that's why I said that the Labour
government that I lead will welcome that
scrutiny will welcome that
accountability we're not going to be
scared of the media we're going to go
out and make the case and win the
argument especially where it's hard you
also talk about a pile-on against the
media and I know that you kind of
referencing that slightly you know the
government and the the conversations
about the BBC but I just wonder do you
think it helps when your rivals in the
leadership contests talk about a biased
media something that of course goes down
very well when they say it in front of
labour hustings well the problem is
talking about the media as one entity
it's a bit like talking about politics
or politicians as one entity you
shouldn't hold labour politicians
responsible for some of the horrendous
things that Boris Johnson and Priti
Patel are currently doing and similarly
you know I launched my lat my election
campaign with my local paper my local
paper actually has done
good job of holding me to account let
alone anybody else over the last few
days your colleague Popeil on against in
this mutiny we're just I think the
language is the problem not the not the
recognition that there's been a series
of individual attacks against labor
politicians particularly all of the last
labor leaders whether it was Jeremy
Corbyn or Ed Miliband or Gordon Brown
they have been treated incredibly badly
by sections of the media there is no
question about that
but the problem comes when we just say
the media is the problem because the
media is the media is incredibly
important and I want to see a far more
open accountable media that's why I said
this week that I wanted to see that the
BBC moved to a more mutual model where
it's much more accountable to the
licence payers fee payers and the people
who actually use it and who fund it and
to the public because that is one of the
best ways to guard against it being
subject to political interference from
this government from a sort of Trump s
Kotak trying to get the BBC to tone down
its criticism of government that's the
safeguard okay and I'm keen to talk
about trans rights because some of your
comments have received a lot coverage in
the last week or so when it comes to
this area now you signed a pledge card
from the Labour campaign for trans
rights which calls on candidates to
support the expulsion from the Labour
Party of those who hold bigoted
transphobic views and the same pledge
card then goes on to say that woman's
place UK which argues for single sex
spaces to be protected is a trans
exclusionist hate group so do you think
then that Labour members like Ruth Sir
Walker who co-founded women's plays like
Julie bindle who've expressed support
for women's pay at place she'll be
kicked out the party no I have to say
that was the part of the pledge that
gave me pause for thought about whether
to sign it but I decided to sign it in
the end because I think that the
sentiment of the pledge about protecting
trans rights and about accepting the
trans men and men and trans women and
women is really important especially at
the moment with the level of
discrimination that people face I don't
think that prescribing organizations is
actually the right way to deal with
disciplinary issues in the labor party I
think that the question for us is always
about individual behavior and it's right
to recognize that there are women who
have fought for generations in order to
create safe spaces for women who want to
have a proper debate about how we best
protect that in an era where we've
recognized that trans men are men trans
women and women and we've got to do far
more to protect trans women from harm as
well and I want to see us have an open
debate I don't want to see us close down
debate and I don't want anybody who's
listening to this to think that I do but
I represent people in my constituency
including a young girl who's currently
going through the gender recognition
process and it is horrendous the level
of discrimination that she is currently
facing and where there are people who
say she a doesn't have rights because
she's trans or B doesn't actually exist
because there is an argument that is
being prosecuted that trans people don't
actually exist that is unacceptable
behavior nobody should be expected to be
in the labour party and hear that said
about themselves and that's where I want
to see action taken I mean you clearly
feel very passionately about supporting
the right of trans people particularly
of course after listening to the cases
in your constituency and but I guess
some feminists would feel that after
signing this pledge card which is
talking about the expulsion from the
labour party of people who hold
transphobic views and then going on to
say that woman's place UK is a transit
exclusionist hate group that is shutting
down the debates so if I give you pause
for thought do you think you should have
signed her but I think that pledge cards
themselves have become a real problem in
British politics and I think with
hindsight if we could have all signed a
pledge card at the beginning to say that
we wouldn't sign pledge cards we'd
probably be in a much better place
because one of the ways that pledge
cards have been used is to pick people
against one another we've seen it happen
with brexit in recent years we've seen
it happen with the Israel Palestine
debate within the Labour Party in recent
months and actually it surely must be
possible for us to have about a level of
debate than this I suspect
years before I came into Parliament
working with young people for the
charity Centrepointe and in our hostels
we always had to work really hard to
make sure that we didn't just have the
policies but the practice is in place to
make sure that we kept young people in
our hostels safe that they were a safe
space for those young people
particularly young women who'd often
experienced domestic violence and we're
still experiencing it when they came to
us so the this is really important to me
it really really matters to me and I
refused to see this as a zero-sum game
between two groups are very
discriminated against very marginalized
often very frightened people labour has
to do better than that we have to stand
for both are you happy for people who
self-identify as women to be on
all-women shortlists yeah I think you
have to you have to walk the walk in the
labour party and that means that we have
to do two things one is that we have to
accept that people are who they say they
are I've never believed that politicians
or even me as an individual should
interfere or dictate to people who they
are and this does actually remind me
very much of the debate around being gay
when I was growing up as a child in the
80s and it really wasn't very well
understood and people you know there are
all sorts of really offensive things
that were were said at that time often
quite maimed by quite mainstream
politicians about how this was a choice
you know not in a not something that was
part of who people were I think we've
moved on as a country and I think with
trans rights we will move on as a
country as well but we're not there yet
so I think it's important that labour
leads by example and I also think we
need to put far more support in place
for people who are going through this
process and they're exploring their own
identity and are coming to terms with
that and are learning how to live in a
country that so far is far too own
accepting of people who are different
and I want to see us do that within the
Labour Party as well the process is not
right for people out in the country but
let's put more support in place in the
labour party we start the interview
talking about the importance to
reconnect with voter things or
traditional working-class and
communities and but this week you've
said that you want to scrap the monarchy
that that's how you'd vote if there was
a referendum on that that you support
free movement of people
you argued that trans rapist should be
allowed to women's prisons is is this
the best way to reconnect with the
voters that you're talking about well no
if I'm really honest I've been asked
about 50 times what I think about the
monarchy and I was very clear when I
talked about the monarchy that I don't
think in any sense that having left the
European Union without a trade deal and
without a plan and with a lot of
people's jobs at risk in working-class
towns like mine that this is a priority
it's all I've been asked probably about
150 times about trans rights in this
contest
I've been asked once about how we're
going to win back bassett law and that's
why on Friday I was in Halifax with a
lot of the local councillors and local
residents and local businesses hearing
from them about what is happening to
them because of the floods and because
of the lack of flood defences these are
the issues that's going to win labor a
general election and that's why I was in
Halifax on Friday because this is the
thing that really really matters to
people at the moment half the country is
under water and yet sections of the
media are asking every labor shape
leadership contender about issues on
which we all fundamentally agree I mean
it's just a nonsense and that's why I'm
determined that we're going to do this
differently and we're going to stand up
for people across this country who want
to see us do better okay and then very
quickly because we are running out of
time and you've said kirsten were all
Rebecca long Bailey wins you would serve
in their shadow cabinet what would you
dream job be it's your chance to pitch
well it did it's sort of defensive
they'd have me I suppose because the
other day care sort of seemed to suggest
that you wouldn't have Becky and I which
she said made her feel quite sad I think
he has since said he would be happy to
serve alongside us but and I suppose
whatever they want me to do is you know
I've always been a team player even
after I left the shadow cabinet I went
off around the Manchester Gorton
by-election for Jeremy Corbyn I will do
my part if they've got a roll around
1990s pop music I think I'd be very well
suited to it rightly faster than that um
well Britney and Taylor Swift as well so
you know whichever area they want me to
do Britney and bosses that's Margo maybe
see a glass of me this year then thank
you listen Andy and Lisa Andy will be
taking part in a special
Sky News Labour leadership debate this
at Thursday that's all we're coming up
I'll be hosting it in twos burry one of
the communities at least who was just
talking about